لمياء احنا كتير يا اهلا وسهلا فيك احنا
كتير كمان حابين نعرف كل هذه التفاصيل
متعلقه بتركيب يدين حقيقيتين لمياء
بالعاده احنا بنسمع عن اشخاص يتم تركيب
اطراف الصناعيه لهم اذا كانوا بحاجه مثلا
لزراعه اطراف كيف حالفك الحظ بان تحصلي
على يدين حقيقيتين ما القصه
الحمد لله انا في السعوديه عشان كذا
حالفني الحظ هذا اول شيء
طبعا بدعم من
الدكتور ممدوح
واكيد دعم
وزير الصحه سابقا توفيق الربيعه جاني امر
سامي من والدي
الملك سلمان والحمد لله
بخصوص المتبرع طبعا كانت
ايوه بخصوص المتبرعين هل تعرفين مين هذا
المتبرع وكيف تم التواصل اللي اخذ يدين
حقيقيتين
لا المستشفى عندهم سياسه انه ما اعرف مين
المتبرع لين يوافقون العائله
وكذلك هم اهل المتبرع معي ما المفروض
يعرفون عني اي تفاصيل لين انا اوافق وهذا
الشيء لسا ما صار ما كنت مستعده وقتها
ممكن بعدين ان شاء الله لكل المشاهدين
اللي بيشوفونا وبدهم يفهموا يعني انت
ضليتي اربع سنين في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تنتظرين متبرع وعلى استعداد
لاجراء العمليه ما الذي حصل حتى تصلين الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
شو صار شو اللي صار معك
طبعا انا بعد هنا سنه بعدها جاني الامر
السامي قعدت هناك في امريكا اربع سنين
انتظر لانه كان في يعني فصيله الدم شويه
صعبه والاشياء هذه بس الحمد لله بعد اربع
شهور واربعه اربع سنين واربع شهور واربع
ايام بالضبط يعني متبرع دكتور ممدوح
دكتور اوكي اليوم لما بنحكي احنا عن هكذا
نوع من عمليات كيف بتم تحقيق التوافق وبان
تتلائم
اليدين مثلا الحقيقين مع زراعتها في جسد
اخر وبمكان اليد الاخرى كيف
نعم هي طبعا بتم بنفس الطرق اللي بيتم
فيها زراعه الكلى مثلا لازم يكون في توافق
دموي بتتعمل تحاليل معينه خاصه بين
الشخصين وبعد الزراعه الشخص لمياء الان
لازم تستمر على ادويه مثبطه للمناعه مدى
حياتها لان هي لو توقفت الان عن هذه
الادويه جسمها يرفض لانه حيتعامل مع
اليدين هذه كانها جسم غريب ويتم رفضها
مباشره فعشان كذا الشخص اللي بيتم زراعه
اي عضو سواء يدين او كلى او قلب لازم ياخذ
الادويه المثبته للمناعه هذه مدى الحياه
طيب ارى شيء امر مهم طبعا عشان العمليه
معقده وعشان يلاقوا شخص
معقده ونادره دكتور طيب نرجع للاميه لمياء
اليوم انت موظفه اداريه هل عدتي الى عملك
بشكل طبيعي هل تستخدمين ايديك الاثنين
بشكل طبيعي حدثيني اكثر
الحمد لله ايوه رجعت للعملين في موظفه
اداريه
تقريبا استخدم ايدين في كل شيء الا بعض
الاشياء الدقيقه الاعصاب يعني يبغى لها
توصل
عندي اليد اليسار عندي الابهام لسه ما
يتحرك يحتاج عمليه بس يعني تقريبا الى
الان الحمد لله يعني يعني زي ما تشوفون في
الفيديوهات كيف حركه اليدين اول وكاف
الحين فرق يعني تقريبا 80% يعني وحتى لم
كمان يعني احنا شايفينك مباشره معنا على
الهوا يعني حتى قادرين نشوف الايدين كيف
عم تتحرك والتشابك بين الاصابع للايدين
اليوم كمان لم قد ايه مثلا انت بتشعري انه
اليوم صار في ضروره واهميه انه الناس
تتبرع اذا كان فيها فعلا انقاذ حياه او
مساعده شخص اخر اليوم
فعلا هذا الشيء يعني غير حياتي وغير مو بس
حياتي حياتي العائله اللي حولي كلهم امي
اخواني انت ما تغير حياه شخص بالتبرع انت
تغير حياه عائله كامله
فهذا الشيء لازم يكون يعني من يعني مثلا
عندنا في ناس كثير مبتورين عندنا في الحد
الجنوبي كثير جنود فقدوا اطرافهم يحتاجون
لهذا الشيء
فان شاء الله يكون في عمليه زي كده قريب
في السعوديه